preview
hey this is Mary Kish standing in for
reviewer Kevin Van Wert to talk to you
about infamous first light in the
standalone adventure infamous first
light
you leave second Suns leading dudebro
Delson behind and fill the neon powered
shoes of abigail walker otherwise known
as fetch fetch must face not only the
wrath of the department of unified
protection but also the creepy commons
from a dirtbag named Shane the dialogue
is heavy-handed and the story is as
predictable as can be but Laura Bailey's
nuanced and emotional performance makes
fetch a delight to spend time with just
tell me where to look
he's shot lately thank you what a pity
that the story missions tie her down
with so many limitations as the plot
leads you through its ho-hum beef you
improv powers and gain access to new
ones by completing missions collecting
glowing shards and performing a few
mundane side tasks such as preventing
drive-by shootings fetches neon based
abilities allow her to speed through the
city as a ray of light and create a
gravitational singularity that sucks in
nearby enemies and then detonates with a
burst of light and limbs yet a good
portion of the story missions have you
playing sniper bolting you to rooftops
and having you fire at the shooting
gallery underneath you how boring
we're first light impresses is in the
fluidity of the interactions speeding
through Seattle is a breakneck delight
particularly when you rush through one
of the countless neon vortexes scattered
about and pick up an additional speed
boost collectible shards that improve
your powers have you screwing up
skyscrapers and floating from rooftops
this is the same vibrant high fidelity
version of Seattle that made second son
such a joy to play there are no
framerate hitches to distract you and
there are little textural Poppins to
annoy you
obstacles are easily surmounted making
the city's borders the only notable
boundary of your freeform exploration
it doesn't take too long to exhaust the
simple secondary activities which is
just as well as wonderful as it feels to
interact with infamous first light the
game simply goes through the motions the
morality system that makes the series
stand apart is missing from action here
so the only guiding principles are your
own not the games given the way Delson
fully embraced his living power fantasy
it's ironic that his story would allow a
noble path of sorts when the more
conscientious fetch would be allowed no
such paths
it's not the open world but in the
challenge rooms where fetch is most able
to let loose zipping from corner to
corner
blasting guards and digital demons is an
absolute blast at least before you earn
the game's full complement of neon
powers the freedom of movement the ease
in which you can chain melee attacks
together the responsiveness of the
controls all of these attributes
combined into a silky demonstration of
Awesome skill once you've maxed out your
homing missiles however the challenge of
combat such as it is is mostly
eliminated you can simply zip from one
neon source to another filling up on
juice and spamming enemies with missiles
until you are able to summon your
singularity and vaporize your attackers
you can continue almost indefinitely
this way combat is far too easy to abuse
and without tension the arenas lose
their luster
nevertheless infamous first light is a
serviceable time waster fetch is an
engaging character troubled yet
intensely loyal and as such commands
your attention of course given second
son's greatness you might have hoped for
something more than the mindless show of
destruction first light is decent fun
but it has no spark our secret if anyone
knew a conduit was in town there'd be a
manhunt and it happened before
but that night I wasn't worried I've
used my powers to get the job done then
the two of us would take off we'd be
miles away for the dup show